chrissy teigen shares what makes
five-month-old son miles the happiest
and he's just the happiest in any
situation ever ET caught up with the 32
year old during the 2018 grammar women
of the Year awards in New York City
where she dished on her and husband
John's little one after sharing this
adorable photo of him cuddled up with
all the teddy bears I think building our
just sent just so many bears and we saw
them all they were like in a little bag
by the couch you know it's like oh my
gosh like all miles my little bear so
you know we just set him up in and he's
just the happiest in any situation ever
and then it turns out he's actually
somehow even more happy surrounded by
ten bears Chrissy also opened up about
what it means to her to be honored as a
woman of the year for her impact as an
influencer on social media I feel crazy
for being here I mean honestly the the
lineup of people is just amazing we're
right next to Biola Davis right now and
I mean it's it really is an honor and I
see John accept these things all the
time and it's you know it's he has a
whole shelf full of them so now I have
one too and I'm very excited this is a
pretty good first big award I'd say so I
know he's not intimidated he is going to
do it concert tonight we're both going
back to work after this and when she
feels most glamorous oh I mean I could
easily say like in a t-shirt and jeans
but now that's not true like I probably
right
it'll probably like the Oscars carpet or
I mean that feels pretty that's
as major as it gets or no really it's
not like a glamorous type of person I
feel glamorous when I see other people
looking glamorous and the whole event
and the whole vibe of the event and
that's what feels lammers to me
[Music]